翻訳: Asami HATANO
校正: Hiroko Kawano
はい みなさん こんにちは
今日はですね まず
とても大きな数字の話からしたいと思います
今画面に出ている
0が80個 並んでいる
これは10の80乗という
大変大きな数字なのですが
いったい皆さん
これ何だと思いますか？
実は これはですね
人類が観測している宇宙
これを構成する原子の数
これを計算で求めたのが
10の80乗
大変大きな数字ですね
今日は この宇宙的な数字を
はるかに上回る
スケールの大きな話を
皆さんと一緒にしていきたいと思います
今日のテーマですが
ゲームです
皆さん どちらかというとゲームというと
コンピューターゲーム ―
こういう物を想像する方が
多いと思います
どんなイメージを持たれてますか？
先ほど学校の先生も
いらっしゃいましたけど
やはりゲームをすると
勉強しないとか
家に引きこもってしまう
例えば暴力的になる
事件、事故を起こす —
こういったネガティブなイメージを
持つ方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
ただ一方で
このコンピューターゲームというのは
日本も大変盛んに
家庭用ゲーム機を世界中に展開して
多くの人たちが楽しむようになりました
昨今ではスマートフォンの普及により
もっともっと多くの方々が
ゲームを楽しむようになりました
そのおかげで色んな問題も 起きています
ただ今日お話しするゲームは
こういったコンピューターゲームではなくて
「トレーディングカードゲーム」
皆さん 聞かれたこと
ありますでしょうか？
なかなかあまり
聞きなれない言葉かもしれません
トレーディングカードゲームというのは
例えばトランプのような
カードゲームの要素
そして 例えば切手を集めるとか
こういう風に何かをコレクションする
この２つの要素を掛け合わせたものが
トレーディングカードゲームといいます
「トレーディング」といいますから
人と交換をする —
交換をするためには
価値が必要なんですね
実はトレーディングカードゲームというのは
１枚１枚のカードに価値があります
例えばこのカード
これは有名な『遊戯王』
というカードゲームですが
人気のあるカードは
１枚120万円で取引されます
１万ドルくらいですね
こういう風に たった１枚の紙でも
大変価値があれば
こういう風に値段がつく訳ですね
ちょっとトレーディングカードゲームのルール
どういう風な遊びなのかを説明します
基本的に自分と相手
１対１で対戦をします
まず 自分の手札 —
山札というのを作ります
だいたいこれが40～60枚
これは自分が好きなカードを選びます
因みにトレーディングカードゲームというのは
色んなアニメ・漫画を
モチーフにしたテーマがありまして
そのテーマの中に
何種類もカードがありまして
その中から自分が好きなカードを選びます
相手も選びます
そしてお互い山札から
５枚を手札にして
そして自分の手札から
モンスターを呼び出したり
魔法を唱えたりして
そして相手と戦います
最後に相手にトドメを刺せば勝ち
この時に自分の手札から呼び出すモンスター
こういったものには
大変人気のある漫画のキャラクターとか
色んなヒーローとか
こういったものが
モチーフになっていまして
自分の好きな 自分の
お気に入りのカードで相手を倒す
まさに 子供たちがワクワクするような要素が
大変含まれているというカードゲームです
ちょっとこの画面を見てください
右側が なんかすごい絵のドラゴン
左側が ネジなんです
みなさん どちらが強いと思いますか？
右側は大変名前も長いですし
数字も7,500とか載っています
普通に考えると 右側の方が
価値も高くて強いです
ところが 実はこれ 条件が変わると
左側が勝つんですね
すこし難しいのですが
この右側のモンスター
こちらには相手の攻撃をブロックするという
「ブロッカー」という
特殊能力を持っていまして
そして自分も攻めるという
大変強いカードなのですが
この左のネジは
ブロッカーを無条件に破壊する
という能力を持っていまして
一瞬のうちに この右側の
ドラゴンを倒すことができる
このように
トレーディングカードゲームというのは
一見価値が高くて
一見強そうに見えるものでも
組み合わせによっては
相手を倒すことができるという
大変戦略的 頭脳的なゲームなんです
実は今ここに映っている
トレーディングカードゲーム
これは『デュエルマスターズ』という
小学生に大変人気なカードゲームです
これは実は 3,000種類のカードがあります
その中から自分のお気に入りの
カードを40枚選ぶんですね
この組み合わせは 一体
いくつあるんでしょうか？
10の91乗通り
つまり全宇宙の原子の数より多いんですね
これ想像できますか 皆さん？
因みに言うと 実はこの
トレーディングカードゲームは
1993年アメリカで生まれた
『マジック：ザ・ギャザリング』という
ゲームが始めとされています
このマジックザギャザリングは
なんと１万種類のカード
その中から60枚を選ぶ
この組み合わせはいくつあるのか？
10の158乗通り
もう全然想像できないですよね
これだけの多くの組み合わせの中から
子供たちはオンリーワンのデッキを選ぶ訳です
どうでしょうか？
すごく創大なスケールで
クリエイティブなゲームだと思いませんか？
私はこのトレーディングカードゲームの
素晴らしさを広めるために
子供たちを相手にした
トレーディングカードゲームの大会を
プライベートで10年以上続けています
子供たちはこういう風に
友達同士もしくは上級生 —
年齢の違う子供たちもたくさん集まって
カードゲームをしています
だいたい小学生以下にしていまして
小さい子は５歳からやっています
大変 戦略的でクリエイティブなので
難しいというゲームですが
５歳からやっています
５歳からやるゲームなのですが
なかなか難しくて
抽象的に物を考えないといけないんです
実は抽象的な物の考え方というのは
だいたい９歳から10歳ぐらい
分数とか文章問題とか
そういった問題を
解ける年齢ぐらいからできる
その壁を超えないといけないということで
「９歳の壁」という考え方があるのですが
まさにカードゲームは 抽象的な
物の考え方をしないといけないということで
これくらいの年齢で大体
カードゲームの対象年齢は設定されています
ところが 私が開催している
トレーディングカードゲームの大会には
５歳の子供がきて
実際にプレイをしています
ひとつここで問題です
「40枚のデッキの中から
初手５枚を手札にする際
欲しいカード１枚が
手札に来る確率を求めなさい」
こんなの小学生に
分かるわけないですよね
大人でも分からないと思います
答えです
12.5%です
当然ですが 私も分かりません
これはデッキに
１枚だけしかない場合ですね
例えば４枚まで存在する場合
どうなるか？
42.7%
だいたい2.34回に１回ということで
これくらいの確率なのですが
皆さん これを頭で分かりますか？
実は トレーディングカードゲームを
プレイしている子供たちは
これを感覚的に分かっています
大体このくらいで来るんじゃないか？
もうそろそろ手札に来るんじゃないか？
これはですね 例えば
野球で言えば
３割のバッターがいて
２回三振をしました
そうすると「多分 次くらい
打つんじゃないか？」というのが
なんとなく分かりますね
実は子供たちもこういう感覚を
カードゲームの中で身に付けていた訳ですね
次に これを見てください
大変 長々としたスクリプト
大変難しいですよね
しかもこの中には
条件分岐がたくさん入っています
こうしたテキストを
５歳から読んでいます
そして５歳から理解して
プレイをしています
なぜかというと
理解できないと
プレイできませんし
楽しめないからです
当然間違っている場合もあります
この場合は
一緒に参加している上級生たちが
教えてあげたりします
こういう風にして
トレーディングカードゲームは
抽象的思考を生み出したり
確率を肌感覚で分かる
こういう風なゲームです
実はそれだけではなく
他に色々な 素晴らしいことを
生み出しています
ある時 私が主催するカードゲームの
大会から帰った子供がお父さんに聞かれました
「今日はどこに行っていたんだ？」と
「トレーディングカードゲームの
大会に行っていた」と
その子は大変成績が良い子供なのですが
「どうだったんだ？」
「負けました」と
「負ける訳ないだろ お前が
お父さんにちょっとやらせてみなさい」と
実はお父さんとその子供が対戦した訳ですが
一度もお父さんは勝つことはできませんでした
その後 そのお父さんがどうなったかというと
子供と一緒にトレーディングカードゲームを
やるようになりました
毎週毎週一緒にプレイをして
そしてカードショップに行ったり
大会に出たり
時にはお風呂に入りながら
「ああいう風に戦えば良かったよね」
そういう風な会話がたくさん生まれる
まさに親子のコミュニケーションも
たくさん生み出しています
また それだけではなくて
大会の時には
基本的には
このトレーディングカードゲームは
コミュニケーションを
基本としていますので
相手とコミュニケーションを
取りながらプレイをし
終わった後は「どうだった？」
という検証をしながら
そしてたまには学びながら
そういう風なコミュニケーションを
生み出している
大変素晴らしい
トレーディングカードゲーム
これを私は10年以上 ずっと
こういった取り組みを続けています
今日 皆さんにお伝えしたいのは
このトレーディングカードゲームというのが
宇宙より大きなスケールの中から
オンリーワンのものを選んで
そして 熱狂して遊べる
ただ 遊びだけじゃなくて
抽象的思考を確立し
そして コミュニケーションを豊かにする
こういった要素を含むものを
多くの方に伝えたいと思います
例えばみなさん
お子さんがいらっしゃったり
将来お子さんができる方が
いらっしゃるかもしれません
そういった時に 子供さんに
ぜひ言って欲しいことが
「勉強しなさい」や「外に出て遊びなさい」
だけじゃなくて
「ゲームをしよう」
「一緒にゲームをしよう」
そういう風に 言っていただきたいと思います
トレーディングカードゲームをすることで
クリエイティブな発想に
満ち溢れた体験ができると思います
ありがとうございました
（司会者）ありがとうございます
（拍手）